dans le cadre du festival futur ancien
le président 4 a proposé quatre jours de
programmation du 16 au 19 juin pour
connecter les communautés de Paris
Saclay ou pour du numérique et des
nouvelles innovations technologiques
on a souhaité faire un tour de ces
quatre jours c'est d'avoir des journées
thématiques sur le made with startup
mais Louise Maker mais vous community et
le dernier jour était dédié aux artistes
pour les relations arressance
pour nous c'était important parce que
c'était le tel l'occasion de passer des
ateliers de préfiguration avec les
partenaires qui nous ont aidés à monter
le lieu qui est le couteau de 104 à un
moment plus d'action et un monde vitrine
aussi pour montrer l'ensemble des
innovateurs et des acteurs qui sont sur
Paris Saclay
chose qui a rapidement marqué les
esprits en général quand les gens
arrivaient c'était les installations
interactives qu'on a pu proposer une
installation pour plonger et explorer la
surface de Mars à travers une interface
interactive donc c'est aussi qui marche
très très bien
et l'autre partie qui était pas du tout
technologique là pour le coup ce sont
les conférences avec Thomas boudalier
qui est entrepreneur qui a confondé
néolan qui a été racheté très
significatif par Paradox et qui est
vraiment un beau parcours d'entrepreneur
et qui a généreusement partagé avec
humour en plus ces conseils pour toutes
les futurs startups qui sont sur le
territoire
une des actions par exemple c'est dans
le cadre de la Journée des makers où on
a eu les fameuses imprimantes 3D on a
aussi des conférences sur les fablabs et
les nouvelles valeurs que ça crée dans
le cadre de la R&D et les entreprises
donc des thématiques assez larges
l'ensemble de ces acteurs qui ont
participé cette journée nous a permis de
bien anticiper maintenant la création
d'un hacker space donc un lieu de
fabrication à la taille du lieu donc
assez intime mais de comment est-ce que
ces nouveaux lieux ces nouveaux
programmes permettent de rassembler des
porteurs de projets qui vont créer
ensemble des nouvelles choses et puis
sûrement se rencontrer et puis créer
qu'on espère montrer l'année prochaine
en 2015 à futur ancienne